so people calling is the biggest vs show
of all time how does it feel to be
walking in this yet again well if it was
wonderful I'm very fortunate to be here
and to be part of the biggest Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show we ever had
now it's madness back here with all
these people running around can you
describe the vibe backstage well I
actually feel like it's calmer than
years before just because I feel like we
have more space it's such a big venue
and it's beautiful so you know it feels
like calmer to me so you guys like we're
usually used to this but soon we'll get
it we'll get like crazy
with all the people watching the
millions and millions of people that are
gonna be watching with thousands in
attendance today do you still get
jitters you still ever get nervous when
you go to walk the runway of course you
know every time you never know what's
gonna happen yesterday I was at the
rehearsal and ice my shoes were very
slippery on the runway so you know I
kind of always went down almost foul so
you know you don't know what to expect
and that's the fun of it that's what
gets you going and you know but once
you're once you step on the rhinorrhea
is just a great feeling one of the
things people always look forward to are
the musical guests now between Harry
Styles and Miguel who would you rather
go on a walking sightseeing tour of
Shanghai with maybe hair styles now a
lot of people see Victoria's Secret
models as perfection so what is your
least angelic quality my least and oh I
dunno
I'll keep it as a secret laughs I was
Andrew secret yes thank you so much for
listening thank you